jean marc morandini pour vous permettre
de revenir au firmament du parc
je vous faire une dame ou faux culs
à
vous la trouvez comment la nouvelle
émission d'arthur à fabuleuse j'adore
arthur et puis en plus il ne me fais pas
de procès pour mon livre
bon donc c'est vraiment génial très bien
vous trouvez pas que la quête de sens de
tf1 a porté ses fruits finalement à bah
oui oui tf1 pour moi c'est aujourd'hui
la chaîne de référence
vous pensez que la ferme rentrer dans
l'objectif louable d'apporter un regard
neuf sur le monde rural
oui puis je pense que c'est un vrai
palliatifs par rapport à ce que faisait
pivot sur france 2 bataille et fontaine
vous êtes un petit peu dur avec avec eux
dans votre livre
il faut quand même du bien aux gens ces
gens là n'ont à huy ces gens là en fait
dispense l'amour et je crois je regrette
beaucoup ce que j'ai écrit sur cauet
cette idée de mélanger les invités
sept-îles et d'avoir des interviews
thématique d'avoir des colonnes d'avoir
des rideaux c'est original non oui je
prends que vous avez pont fait sur lui
d'ailleurs ouais bah oui je vais
inventer ce qu il ya tout à inventer la
simplicité d'un stéphane bouillaud le
présentateur de l'île de la tentation ça
vous oui ça me touche d'autant plus que
c'est vraiment une star
ouais je crois que tout le monde l'a
imagine tout de suite et voient tout de
suite qui s'est épanouie
oui mais bien parti est ce que vous
arrivez jean-marc a raté un seul merci
pour l'info l'émission d'emmanuel chat a
jamais jamais on met des millions ont
regardé cette action chaque soir
d'ailleurs moi j'adore carole rousseau
et vous ah bah oui moi moi je rêve de
passer un week end avec assez dommage
que scrupule a été supprimée nabawi
c'était c'était là encore c'est vraiment
une émission de référence à oui et ça me
manque en fait ça donc je l'enregistrais
je me repasse les cassettes chez moi
montiel montiel c'est bien le mec super
cultiver non
je m'en fous
radio ce vendredi face à l'heure si
belle